and I know that this has been a
contention sir yes making it up no we've
talked about this she just said hey
Chris you know what Matt makes me feel
bad I'll talk to you later she didn't
say it like that okay she said for sure
that you make her feel worse than I
do come on
dude
Runk hello
hello
hello hello will
hello starting make the thing jump
off Arabian king in the 13th century
what they would make people jump off
cliffs to prove their uh obedience they
would die correct it's not good
obedience what good is obedience if you
are going to die with it it proves to
like the most obedient guy dies V heads
of state would visit like other
territories and to show his power he
would like I forget which guy but it was
a specific guy he would walk go on
Horseback with that other head of state
through his the valley he controlled the
people would have like a his guys would
have a bird's ey view to attack yeah and
he would just like give some physical
command and the guys would jump off to
like in deference to their King yeah and
the King it would be a fle vast
deference to the king yeah it would be a
uh uh an vast deference to the king king
vast Defence and die yeah exactly well
but that sucks actually if Kings used to
do that make PE make people jump
over the hills and then die is that um
the most obedient dudes basically were
you were losing and that's not good for
well they wouldn't have like all of his
men do it everyone jump off and then
they get a attack oh this was a bad idea
bad timing yeah yeah oh I want a Coke
this is a bad idea I guess I'll get it
myself they didn't have Cokes actually
back then yeah stickler
stickler um hey dude I'm G first of all
Detroit Cleveland and Pittsburgh I'll be
there coming here soon October uh 19th
20th and 21st I believe um most
workingclass cities in America on your
birthday yeah I'm Mr Russ belt dude
that's who I am I'm Russ belt what rust
t belt
what date where are you going to be
dring it what where are you going to be
on my
birthday uh Pittsburgh I'll be in
Pittsburgh Pennsylvania and then I'm
going to Cleveland and then Detroit and
then I'll be in Long Beach actually
November 2nd I just announced that I'm
going to do a that that's where I'm
going do a new material then back to the
Don't Push Me Tour uh Orlando Florida
Fort Meers Richmond Virginia and you
know that's how it's going to be from
now that's how it's going to be do you I
always think about this about musicians
okay I started thinking about it with
comedians with since you've been on this
tour uh does it MH like every night
doing the same song like I think about
big bands they have their hits like that
seems like misery to me what about
comedy with the same different it it it
it I find different ways to say stuff
and I'm the jokes are always kind of
evolving okay but it still it is you you
mean you're paying attention in in a way
that allows it to feel different every
single time so well or to me it's like
I'm working on it I'm working on it to
become the best it can be okay so then
when I shoot it after that I have a huge
then it's way harder to do it again you
after you shoot the special yeah and I
already have the special in the can so
now since it's done yeah now what I I I
I keep saying I'm gonna do the don't
push me tour the way it has been I
always do this I'm gonna do whatever
I've been doing until that special comes
out then I'm going to do new stuff and
then every time I go on stage I'm doing
it I'm doing it and then I do like 30
minutes of new stuff oh and I just can't
bring myself to do it the whole hour so
the last time I
performed the don't push me tour the way
it is going to be on the special was the
special was the special uh and and
what's what's actually sucks for me is
um
I I should just do that over and over
and over again do all the cities make
the money and then come up with the new
material and then go back to those
cities yes and then make that money but
instead I cannot bring myself to do that
so what happens is I will mix the
material up now from now on and then
I'll have to think about later on oh
well I did Pittsburgh I did some of that
new stuff in Pittsburgh maybe I won't do
Pittsburgh too early it's a lot harder
okay okay now we're cooking now we're
getting somewhere AR it's pretty cool uh
it's a pretty cool and why can't you
bring yourself to do it I I I guess I
could I just
it's it's boring okay because I know I
have it here's another reason too it's
either I I did it it was one of the best
times I ever did the show was when I
shot it in Minneapolis and what if I
keep doing it and think of better ways
to do the joke I'm going to be so upset
I didn't take that so I almost don't
want to do it there's a few reasons um
now we're really getting somewhere
before we get into the pinpoints here uh
what's happening musicians have it I
think I think honestly way worse yeah
it's terrible my buddy in Chicago just
recently saw Peter Gabriel and he's
doing sledgehammer and I well I was like
what does he still do like he has to do
the hits like I saw Michael McDonald at
the bowl semi they don't want they want
to do the old stuff he they don't want
to do the old stuff but he the crowd
wants the crowd it's all the crowd wants
I know that that's way worse cuz for me
I'm just never going to do I mean people
still like do this bit do the [__]
Fitness bit do drunk girls I I just
won't do it right yeah I won't do it
apparently neither does Peter Gabriel
and everybody was mad bummed that's way
but that's you got give 30,000 people
who are buying a ticket and they're
there to see sledgehammer and the worst
song of all time soulsbury Hill I want
to be on record somewhere saying that
cuz that is the worst song ever that's a
great song Hammer yeah
okay wow wow wow wow wow the guy in
Police Academy anyway uh yeah dude uh go
sign up for Lifeline Luxury patreon.com
Line luxury new episode out today
Lifeline luxury is where we do uh
episodes of us just Bantam I just love
the Bantam so good a bite um and uh yo
pull that video up for later that's so
funny but um and uh so that's what you
can do there it and just uh there's a
lot of um Lifeline lery uh videos that
you can go access now if you sign up
today at this point we stacked a bunch
you better get in there yeah now listen
I'm going to be honest with you do not
send any more Jordan with
the Jordan with the Slime you clearly
don't get it you're clogging it no it's
not that you're clogging up our uh
megabytes yeah
with so we can't the problem the problem
is this is an advice show and it has un
not with us without us trying to make it
it has turned into a
yeah show it was fun for a little bit
but you guys got so excited and kept
saying CH and we can't have that dude we
love talking about J but we can't do
only J so there we go uh if you have a
question uh please you know click the
link in description below and don't send
a CH and so uh or hit the hotline
one-onone ofice sessions with Matt go to
mata.com and the lifeline merch is at
lifeline merch.com and if you don't get
the merch you don't love us you don't
love me and my family so uh more than
that they specifically wish Terrible
Things upon us if they don't get every
single piece of merchandise from the
store many many men wish death
me so insecure however that singer
whatever that is that's the most
insecure style of
singing yeah you might as well laugh
off
yeah yeah that's what it sounds like
you're going to do a
talk to me my to me BL what up homie
it's wow okay don't know what that is
but it's another 50 old white dudes
would say 50 Cent 50 cents how bad is
that how bad is it when as worse as 50
Cent that's worst well the the worst is
when someone calls him fitty like some
white guy in like a blue brother shirt
you never heard somebody call him fitty
just fitty fitty dude no that's I'm
cringing even though you're you're
calling it out dude let's watch that
clip go ahead there it is right which
one the king of banther one this yeah
weird already getting mad searching for
a man to take off oh this is to but
where's the One Clip though
M do you know where you don't know where
it is I don't know Anthony's doing this
right now yeah I know that can't have
the problem with Anthony is that he
can't do anything right there left left
left it's probably the the short no yeah
you like someone who can give banter as
much as they take listen I'm like king
of banter wow bold state
I'll tell you I love sick
it as they can take never closed his
mouth the whole
time I love
sick sick it you love Yeah sick it you
know what's interesting about people who
don't close their mouth yeah crocodile
their breath smells terrible crocod
they're crocodiles yeah dude it's so why
do they they they talk about B
like it's
B it's just
talking no but B I mean you know benter
is a specific thing yeah flirting well
no we don't we do benter on the show
we're not flirting with each other right
you know what I mean but with benter is
like you're riffing you're like giving
it back to each other bo bo bing bing
bang bang bang bang bing bing bing no
but it's it's just talking really is
what it is
B
wow all right right all right
hates when I do
it all right so next or let's do a new
one know all right yeah hey Matt hey
Chris my name is Stephanie and I'm 26
years old
I have a birth mark on my neck oh well
that looks a lot like a hi I already
know where they are um so a lot of times
people will get a tou like meeting in
public or friends of friends or whatever
who haven't met me will be like oh like
what' you do last night who gave you
that uh and it's kind of annoying it's
not something that offends me but I
always wish I had like a good clap back
for it
um but yeah also I know it's like way
too big to actually be a it's even more
Anno drafted so if you guys have like
any advice on things I could say in
response to
that thanks I love the podcast and
everything you guys do bye thanks great
I got a great one you notice notice the
the hickey like birth mark the way that
she said role play you're saying yeah be
somebody and I'm her hey uh you oh what'
you do last night see I I see your neck
your [__] dad sucked on my neck while
I [__] him
sick dude I uh I only said dad cuz I was
being her yeah yeah yeah I know I
obviously not my dad because that would
be your dad that's what you're saying
well that doubly would be bad I love I
love it ke sick it yeah yeah um or you
can get a circle tattoo a circle around
and little writing say this is not a
hick birth mark yeah that would be a bit
going a bit like bending too far to the
annoying people would be so annoying so
awesome if you circled it and then
pointed to it and wrote sick in it on it
yeah that would be good okay do it again
I'll do it again okay hey whoa somebody
had fun last night what's that all about
your [__] dad did it after I [__]
slobbed on his [__] knob you gave me
a big ass [__] hickey what's
up okay you'd be thrown out of the party
so overboard yeah no no if she did it it
would be fine okay other
people cake falling off their
Fork the kids's birthday
party pop a balloon that scared me when
you did the pop I mean you know I'm I'm
sorry I bet I bet everyone watching at
home rewind just a little bit and zoom
in on my face I bet I flinched yeah when
he did it okay in an unauthorized
fashion unauthorized fashion oh okay
second second all right so uh yeah I
think that that's good and that kind of
or just rock turtlenecks all the time I
so dope but then you're cow or not cow
you're um yeah exactly you're kind of
giving into what would what would you
suggest you're I was going to say your
dad sucked my neck last night next oh
next go yeah yeah go like this next what
else you got go like this go like
this your dad
next that would be really good point to
the other person that you also don't
know who's seeing you for the first time
and say what you got you know let's get
out of the way what you got that's good
that's good oh hey whoa what an original
[__]
yeah I wish someone would do that kind
of [__] I want to be friends with
somebody like that but dude if anyone's
going to be doing that [__] it's me man
yeah you should do it yeah be the be the
be the change you want to see in the
world that's and that's why people say
that is because they want me to do that
yeah yep okay so she called in because
she wanted you to do that you're saying
I think people want me to be the change
that they want to see the World by being
like doing [__] like [__] you know oh
what an original guy next sick in it
what an original [__] was what it
really was the first original that is
way better okay all right next
one what's up Bros much love from
Bulgaria if you know where that is yes
anyway that was a really bad we I'm
going to keep going though um my
question to you guys is how much weight
or importance should uh be placed on
political views when picking a
significant other uh I found that um as
I get a little bit older I'm getting a
little bit more into global politics and
economics and I feel like it's starting
to play a a bigger role in my life and I
feel like my partner should have at
least the same um views I guess you
could say or the the same morals or
values that one I guess stance takes so
uh I don't know just wanted to hear you
guys' thoughts on that thanks I I I I I
I
I it it I try to look past it it doesn't
matter really too much to me I mean look
the truth is you're probably going to
end up with someone who feels the way
you feel because it's you know like
attracts like right people with similar
beliefs end up generally in similar
circles you know so the likelihood of
you meeting someone who shares generally
your political beliefs is high you know
but that being said if you fall in love
with somebody uh or just want to do the
horizontal Mambo with someone and they
want to do the horizontal Mambo with you
and you happen to have different
political beliefs consensual horizontal
shouldn't really matter like that also
there are people like famous political
figures like James Carville has been
married to this hardcore Republican for
like 40 years or something that's wild
it's crazy and that idiot uh and that
other idiot George Conway and kellyan
Conway they only recently or something
yeah but they were together forever they
have like 18 19y old daughter you know
they both realized they were different
political values and Mary mine that's it
yeah yeah yeah Mary Magdalene exactly
Mary Magdalene uh but the it shouldn't
yeah it shouldn't shouldn't really
matter she's a
republican um but yeah yeah no I think
uh it shouldn't matter and I've been
with both sides of the spectrum uh uh
and it shouldn't matter and it it
doesn't to me uh but there were times
where I was like H I know she thinks
that and that's kind of sure but that's
normal though like you don't you you
you're an i ideologue if you refuse to
date anybody who differs from your
political op stupid also if I like pasta
and you hate pasta that's not a thing
that's a bigger deal yeah I know you're
going eating a lot more I love pasta and
I don't want to have to eat less of it
and no matter who's the president most
likely your life is the same although in
Bulgaria I don't know if you have Lords
or whatever you have over there Lords
the biggest idiot ever
I don't know if you have you know the
thing I want to talk about this guy are
his green eyes and what I wanted to talk
to you about was how he's probably a cat
at night he turns into a cat at night so
he's obviously liberal so he has green
what do you mean they weren't green I'm
just being a contrarian oh okay yeah he
was green green Green those were Green
Green Eyes Green are green eyes are
really rare man and he had green green
green green green eyes a phone
ringing green green green green eyes
hello um yeah I uh think he had
greenish eyes and I think that
um I think that bulgarians have
Lords oh okay
that's is that your political opinion
they don't what do they have then smarty
pants well basically no one has Lords
anymore because it's you B Google it
it's not
1412 you know yeah B Google it yeah
what's that Bard Google bard
Google does somebody want to explain it
to him no one knows what that means you
made it up just right now B Google okay
what is happening it's Google's version
of AI oh really chat oh I don't like
that at all like Shakespeare the B The
Bard I don't know The Bard dude get out
of here I'm just saying anyway boo
Google boo all right all right all right
well let's do the next one
then hey guys love you so much um so my
issue is I live in Charleston South
Carolina love it wait open parenthesis
Chris please come to Charleston want you
I'll be there next next year close
parenthesis oh he's going to be there so
anyways um I'm in my last year of law
school here and I work for an attorney
I've worked for for a few years I love
him he's become like family to me um he
bought me a car like not to get into the
whole relationship but we're really
close so when I graduate I'm going to go
work for him I'm going to move closer to
where I work and he happens to have a
house there that they just moved out of
and he's renting it out now and I've
house sat there before I'm super
familiar with the house great house and
he was like instead of buying or renting
another apartment just move to our house
rent it from us we'll take your rent out
of your payche that way neither of us
have to pay taxes on it saves a lot of
money blah blah blah illegal and at
first I was like oh that's like a really
good idea but it's also the beginning of
hor F thinking about it and I was like
well and maybe this was just like me
being paranoid but
do I want to put all my eggs in one
basket like that all at once like no I'm
working for him I'm driving the car he
got me I'm living in the house he's
renting to me and it seems like a lot I
don't think anything is going to go
wrong at least in the near future with a
really great personal and work
relationship but it's like hey have you
ever heard of a house of something go
wrong hey have you ever heard of a house
of C do I want my entire life tied to
like one person or one career one job he
have you ever heard seems a lot and I
don't know if saying
to his offer is like offensive just be
like because he knows it's like a really
great chance too I don't know if he
would be offended by me saying like uh
let me not like it just seems like a lot
oh you didn't think about that I don't
know all of your advices would be
helpful say yeah like what if you clog
the [__] you take a big fat dump [__]
and it [__] gets all clogged up and
you got to call the owner and he has to
fire you and you got to get fired you
got to go all the way to court say I got
fired for improper reasons I was taking
a big fat [__] in his house and the the
toilet was bad and I
got order
order dump [__] what is this dump
[__] um stripping
stripping dude why is Sandstorm the
stripper
song this is gross no matter what who
whoever does it do you know what I mean
like this as a stripper move is bad no
matter what not if you're you got the th
all out right here like this right and
it's shaved and it's nice second second
it if you go like this you just like
this and then you go up to the guy and
you go second in it you doing that made
me upset well cuz I thought about you
doing it at like a strip club and it was
very dancing were just doing it as if
you were at a strip club so I have a
good imagination man I would never be at
a strip club dancing at a strip club I I
would kill it if I did oh really yeah oh
okay I thought maybe you would I mean of
course I know that you would not do that
but I well well you know what I might as
a joke or to make some cash yeah little
cash but for guys though that wouldn't
be I wouldn't want to do it for guys or
or unattractive women only attractive
women I would want to do only for my
wife at this point I would only do it
for my wife are there like gay strip
clubs I mean that probably is a stupid
question oh yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah are
there for women women for women no right
I've never well there's that Thunder
Down Under yeah there's dude you yeah
there's for women Bachelor it's it's not
it's something that women are like no I
don't want to do it but then they all
get there and they're like oh oh you
know this is oh my God oh God and then
before you know the guy's got the towel
in front of him and he's do like just
suck it a little bit it's all good and
she's
like and then the like did you do it and
she's like no I'm talking about women
strippers for women like there's male
strippers for men no well allans into
that I'm saying all women strippers are
for women too because all strippers are
also lesbians you know what I'm saying
oh I mean I that made sense what you
said but I don't think I agree all
strippers are lesbians the more trauma
you have the
more stuff you got going on you know
what I mean so that's independently true
yeah but more trauma you got going on
makes you more likely to be a stripper
yourself more likely to be open to
everything in the world okay so not I
got throw bread at my head why well you
know what I
mean just I could be into that the bread
at the head kink
I've heard of that uh yeah so it's
called carb heading but um yeah you know
I don't know man I I I think that you
know oh yeah what does this girl do what
what do we what what she AIC what should
she do she's a paral paral paralal um
she
should
not it's too yeah I agree it's too much
your instinct is right it's too much but
what's he thinking like why is he well
he well what I take it as I'm joking
about the W oh like he's going to want
to
[__] you know but what I
think it is is like he's just like a I'm
making it up that he's like a close
family friend or something that knows
that wants to help her and then it just
turned into another thing or you know or
he's just a nice guy my question
is like for her would be if she was
still here would be like she was never
here is he ever has he ever given any
hints that he wants to be horizontal in
with you that he wants to
do no I don't think she would have said
that right yeah I mean it seems like it
it was on all on the level you know
although she is an attractive female and
he's obviously older so I don't know you
know who knows there's always that
really when a guy Rel which why I get
why you wouldn't want to right take him
up on that house part right if it's a
good enough deal though I mean what's he
going to I mean you yeah he's a [__]
lawyer for [__] sake so you know he I
guess that's true yeah it's probably
okay but I just think beyond that
reason I wouldn't want to live in my
separate yourself yeah from yeah it's
just too much that's good say as as your
employee I would feel extra Stress and
Anxiety inhabiting a home that my boss
owns and I think that I'd be more
relaxed in a home that is is mine and if
I were to I don't know ruin something I
wouldn't the stakes wouldn't be that
high it would just be a thing that is
mine yeah but living in the house D I
mean I would never want to live in my
boss's
home I live in my boss's home Calvin
well no I'm the boss you I'm my boss
that does work though obviously so it
works fine don't even say that it's
uncomfortable for me sometimes you know
what I mean um yeah I you know it's but
I think that's the thing you said I
think that's how you get out of it you
say I don't think living in my boss's
home I think that would add anxiety to
my life and you're great and you've been
great to me and this is a great offer
but I think even though it'll end up
costing me a little bit more money I
think it's worth it for me to not I
guess yeah I guess that's you think she
should take it no I don't think she
should I think the way I'm saying is the
most
reasonable way and understandable way to
get out of it without even remotely
being insulting making it specifically
about him or anything like that cuz it's
you have the benefit of it being true
which is always good when you want to
get out of a thing always go to the
truest possible excuse you don't want to
make up something CU you're going to end
up getting caught in a dumb lie don't
tell the dumb lie just tell the truth
right especially when the truth is
relatable and understandable in this
case it is bing bong bing you got it all
right oh I'm sorry am I boring you I
agree I'm sorry am I boring you it's all
good next
one hello guys mad Chris Philippines
just so stuned been a longtime fan of
the show especially with congratulations
I was one of those people who was very
very sad when it stopped I've got one
question though what do you think about
people who's doing karaoke was already
bad enough but then just certain regular
people trying to copy a seniors or an
artist voice like you know
artist uh like Brian Adams or like the
the vocalist from the Creed who have
this recognizable distinct voice it's
already bad enough when you're doing
karaoke but then you're trying to copy
their voice which definitely not going
to come out or going to sound the same
but then they're still trying that so
this guy's a kind of this guy was made
by an AI bro this is this guy's question
like of all the questions you know this
guy loves yeah of course he does of
course he does this
he from again did he didn't say it did
he phpp he did Philippines he is from
the pH Filipinos just they want to kill
it on the karaoke there's actually a big
uh I weirdly read this article about uh
karaoke in the Philippines it's like a
massive part of their culture and it
gets so serious that people have been
killed over certain things that W so
he's trying to save lives basically my
way Frank sinach my way which is a
common K song it's the biggest song
there and if you do it or do it wrong or
do it a certain way with too much
machismo people will kill you it's true
I might be actually getting like some of
those details wrong but it's basically
that is that crazy whatever oh dude I
would get killed immediately it was in
the New York Times there you go what is
that it no Ki song that killed countless
people oh the my way killings I mean
dude oh my gosh look at that the my way
killings are a social phenomenon in the
Philippines to a number of fatal
disputes which arose to this in the
singing of the song my way and I'll do
it my
way they're all nurses so they all help
um yeah I don't
mistakes I've made
a a
silencer and I'll do it
my way no no
[Laughter]
no dude what is wrong with you people
stop killing people at a karaoke bar cuz
they saying my
way damn dude I didn't realize I was
going to be that right you know how
sometimes you remember a story and
you're like you start telling it and
you're like uhoh now I'm in the middle
of I'm in midair without a parachute and
I forget some of the details and then
you could tell it with authority even
though you're not sure that's what I did
but I was right that's my whole life
that's my whole
life um all right well um so to the
guy's
question that when it's actually a good
good good question and here's why it's
very specific and it also is a thing
that I've encountered in my life and
thought about when someone sings a song
like the actual singer of the song but
obviously worse because they're not
singers or at least not famous popular
singers it is upsetting and annoying
sing it bad sing it like like you yeah
you know what I mean that's the fun of
karaoke so not with arms open not like
that you just go like With Arms Wide
Open like me like how I would do it I
guess so I guess that's a good example
[Applause]
or that's better than singing it yeah
how about what about this
one you have to you have to right but
but that's a song specific once there
was this girl
you're not going to you know got into an
accident didn't go to wrote it in in 30
minutes that song
anything okay wait hold on this is a
specific question try to get it right
it's not that it's the most 9s thing the
crash test dummies but more than
anything else it could have only been
popular in the '90s more than any other
thing that was popular in the '90s even
the Macarena the Macarena could be
popular now in some way shape you're
you're right you're right but the crash
DK dummies the way they looked the music
video for that song and that song
particularly especially could only be
popular like yeah in the 199 I'm not
sure if it was in on the soundtrack in
the movie singles but it definitely was
do you know what I mean it basically was
yeah uh singles dude yeah yep remember
how the uh we had like a
living nanny for a little while her name
was Rachel yeah uh and she was so stoked
about seeing singles oh yeah that she
went and came back and she cried so much
that she was still crying when she got
home why it was a and she wanted to see
it again no not it's a cam and Crow
movie but then what the hell was she so
sad about she was just like so deeply
moved by singles wow she cried at the
season the series finale of cheers and
another time she cried was when you
called her pizza face dude okay man
listen dude I just wanted to make sure I
got that in there because it's true and
anything you say in reputation is false
I I so go ahead that was a big mistake I
should not have done that Oh I thought
you were going to say something else no
but she told me in confidence that you
make her feel bad all the time and I
know that this has been a contention sir
yes making it up no we've talked about
this she just said hey Chris you know
what Matt makes me feel bad I'll talk to
you later she didn't say it like that
okay she said for sure that you make her
feel worse than I
do come on dude no one has even ever
said that to anybody you know what's
interesting makes me feel worse than you
do you know I called her Pizza F that it
was so shitty I actually I was 12 such a
bad thing to do I genuinely still still
feel bad and I remember she used to wear
a mask with sausage peppers on it but I
don't her eye mask had pepperonis on
it I remember she had a big [__]
doughy head but no um no can we be clear
as to why he called her Pizza cuz she
had an acne problem she was an adult and
some shitty little [__] [__] kid like
this one all right called her pizza face
d a brat can I can I tell you something
though the truth of it is I didn't call
her pizza face because she had an acne
problem I called her pizza face because
I didn't think she had an acne problem
she I knew she felt bad about having
zits and so was so mad at her so I dug
deep and I [__] hit her with real
real hard with that so I'm sorry what is
it wasn't because she had acne it was
because I knew it would make her feel
bad oh so you're even worse okay no I
mean that's fine I have to be honest
with you I still feel bad about that I I
actually still feel bad about get in
touch with her should get in touch with
her make amends ew her that pizza face
yeah
well dude she's probably like 60 now
dude waa no she wasn't that much older
no no no no she's she's in her mid-50s
right yeah but I'm just
like remember when they did that at the
Olympics yeah that was the Atlanta
Olympics so we the reason I know I know
was Atlantic you know you know why is
cuz that awful movie Richard juel
directed by Clen
Ewood is about the 96 Olympics Atlanta
and there's a scene in the movie that at
least attempts to capture the Macarena
craze and it's the worst movie in the
world and that's the worst scene M I
know that movie when did that come out
Clint Ewood just makes movies that no
one even knows about ever I know and
then he's just like I'm done with that
movie what's the next one he was like
the first streaming service you know
like now there's movies that come out
and you're like wait that's out what is
that what is that or there's just just
hype around a movie and they're like oh
[__] and then 3 Days Later everyone
forgets about it Clint Eastwood was that
before before streaming services cuz you
he would have you like oh my God
cleanwood oh my God and then and then
you'd be like what was now it's like
what was the one with the car dude he
like Gran Turismo gr tesmo Grand gr
Torino I know that's the joke oh okay
okay that's the joke yeah good joke good
joke cuz you don't remember and you
think of the video game got it godamn it
got it got it St on now uh clean for w
the weirdest career ever dude
dir har and now he's just all like cut
got
it I mean Jim Carrey you want to do it
again before that no before that he was
a spaghetti western star who like never
spoke in Italian movies then he was a
big movie star then he started being a
director of like Prestige [__] that
people thought was good like Unforgiven
then he did like the stockiest [__] in
the '90s remember no and then now he
just makes movies with people like Matt
Damon that no one in the world has ever
seen even Matt Damon's wife hasn't seen
that movie that he was in with with the
in Hereafter or whatever oh that one oh
Invictus that one too one he did that
one too yeah yeah wow yeah makes like a
movie a year that's two takes I've ever
seen doesn't even watch the monitor you
know yeah he goes like this and
action in the middle of Matt Damon's
line cut got it yeah sure doesn't he um
not say action I think that's right
actually yeah they just start he's like
I don't know what he says but it's like
start whenever you want yeah so low
energy you know that can't even bring
himself to to do the qu's going to do it
from bed uh
today he just says do it I don't know do
it no he he just told me to tell you to
do it he I think he has the um
headphones on anyway go ahead there's no
way of knowing but also it wouldn't make
a difference anyway cuz you're only
going to get to do it once why do actors
like that working with him it's like let
not me dude no not me not me oh not me I
I sit out the first take I I I'm telling
you okay I'm Johnny first take okay yeah
so Clen Ewood if you're listening which
you probably are or watching you're
probably watching actually I know you
love to watch YouTube and especially
this show let me just tell you this C
Chris this is the most annoying thing
that the most annoying thing about doing
why are you laughing bro
I don't know I'm just anticipating what
you're the most annoying thing about
acting and or doing a movie probably
mostly for actors nah anybody but the
director is that you you have to do the
same
thing 15 times uhhuh that sucks this is
why I don't understand besides the money
obviously why actors ever would want to
do screen acting yeah it doesn't the
money is well they want to be a star
right which is money but the craft of it
it's [__] it sucks it's so peac mail
it's so repetitive the amount of times
you have to do it for everyone else
especially on a TV show where they just
get blindly get coverage of anything if
there's four or five people talking in a
room everyone gets their medium shot
everyone gets their close-up every
single time all those actors are off
camera feeding the lines to the actor
whose shot it is dude it's so boring and
even even if you're Leonardo DiCaprio
let's you like let's not use him cuz he
literally can do any movie he wants but
like you know Tom Hardy like the the
next tier of movie star in any given
movie he's
doing four scenes that are awesome for
him to do right okay I mean all right
and other than that the scene is this
the scene is this you're off you're
off yeah I mean it would be a better
shot because your head is cut off and he
gets home and hey put and you got to do
that nine times yeah I mean a lot of
times big stars have a a double do those
things but not if it's going to be you
know well L sooner or later it'll be a
[__] AI right but no but it'll be
like someone else doing it and then
their face will be obscured you know
what I mean right no I understand
always do that they but I'm saying is
how many scenes do you get where you
really got to make you make get to make
a meal of it [__] four I even if
you're even if writing it am I writing
it 100% of the imagine how exhausting
that movie would be at the end yeah well
that's the other thing people don't want
to see that wall to wall just like but
that yeah I do want to see that actually
yeah I don't get it I don't get it's so
weird that people want to do it just
because I think people want to be actors
because they think they want to be
actors yeah watch this though
okay you know what I'm saying and cut
yeah yeah you know what I'm doing we
have to replace Matt that's just me
that's just me like Banta oh SI it but
it's acting bant it you can do that if
you want cut isn't it all right uh next
one oh my God SAR and Autumn here again
thank you so much for your advice you're
here um my fiance and I watch it
together so that was fun um quick
question when are you going to get true
baby here in the merch store for True
babies
interesting um no but my real question
is and it's a little s deeper good okay
those are the best question what do you
guys think about
mediums and I asked this because um 2
and a half years ago I lost my younger
sister and there's some circumstances
around her death that will never know oh
no um there was another person
involved and the only people that know
would be that person and obviously my
sister who is no longer with us
um do you think going to a medium
would you know maybe get some answers
for questions that I have or give a
little bit more to what ha happened
around her death um
what do you guys think of Med shut the
[__] up or do I just kind of just come
to terms I'll just never have those
answers that sucks I'm really sorry let
me know yeah uh no the mediums no there
just there's no werewolves either you
know here's what I say if it's if you
have specific
questions I don't believe that mediums
are right and [__] this is not what I'm
saying I believe the answer is no okay
you know what I mean just she's here ah
she's here yeah don't what I was going
to say is
don't don't let your pain make you a
sucker is all I'm saying it's fine to go
to them and explore it and see if you
Vibe with someone and see if they like
say interesting [__] and they're not a
[__] like Huer
but
uh
generally what are they going to
possibly do not generally they're going
to hold your hand and just going to be
like I sense her in the
room me yeah it's like and there was a
tip this is a long history of these
people praying
on broken people and not that you're
broken but in this instance this is
something that broke your mind probably
it certainly broke your heart really
sorry about that that's and uh and Chris
keeps like literally every time I talk
he just cuts me right off and it's
really annoying but uh yeah the answer
is no but I don't think it would be
would make you stupid to go and check it
out like well every circumstance is you
it's not SM if you think it'll make you
feel better potentially try it but don't
get sucked into some [__] where
someone's like buking you for money I
mean I've read stories where these
people [__] get people's savings
because they've made someone believe
that they're in touch with their dead
father or dead brother or whatever the
[__] you know it's just not true it's
only entertainment and it'll only either
make you feel better or not but it has
nothing to do with reality uh and
there's no that's true of a lot of
things though there's no ghost yeah well
I mean a lot of people think religion is
that you know but um right exactly so if
that makes you feel better and it helps
you get through life as long as you're
not being hurt in the process either
financially or mentally or whatever
spiritually whatever you want to say you
monetarily yeah be careful is is the
thing I would say it's just it's if
you're if you're asking if it's real or
not though the answer is resoundingly no
um and there's no werewolves and there's
no uh Half Men half
sharks okay glad you got that that in
there and there's no ghosts okay I mean
so scared that there's ghosts the way
you said that and no matter what it's
not scary at night when I go to bed all
right uh and there's no frogs okay see
you man there no straight frogs that's
for sure cuz the water turned them gay
okay
bye hi Chris hi Matt it's Lucy from
Manchester quick question so me and my
boyfriend are going to New York this
month for his 30th birthday and we've
got everything planned in terms of like
you know the day today but we wanted to
catch a comedy show whilst we're out
there so if there's any recommendations
that you've got as to where we can head
that' be great because it's kind of hard
to know whether a place is going to be
good or bad um also any good coffee
place recommendations that' be also
helpful and we love it when you take the
make out of people that are from the UK
so if you can do an impression of me or
someone from Manchester that'd be great
thank you I don't when I'm I don't know
who the [__] is from where in in London
I got one thing I do and it's this well
I know that people who sound like that
are from Manchester exactly my here's
the thing about Manchester is that
everyone from Manchester is named Lucy
if they're a woman and Lucy is the
most I mean it's crazy to be from
Manchester named Lucy it's just like
you're the most
mancherian human being imaginable okay
yeah
uh go to the comedy seller and but
except for you have to wait that's
really hard to get in I would honestly
say there are like really there's so
many good comedians around New York that
you can just go to the stand you can go
to New York comedy club you can go to
Comedy seller you'll see good comedians
I think um so yeah when I lived there I
used to go to the comedy mus forever ago
but that was where I that was a lot of
fun when I would go to The Comedy Store
legitimately great Comics only like
thank you there's only like 10
110 uh seats in it so pretty Co tiny try
to go on a weekday I guess yeah it's
always sold out but and um and then uh
what was the other question coffee shops
I I don't know I haven't been there in
so long I yeah I haven't been there in
Forever you've been there more recently
yeah but I go for a day and then I come
back you know yeah oh what was that one
good place ah [__] I I'll never
remember uh it was in it was it was oh
also it's not it's not worth it cuz I
don't know where you're staying it's
like sometimes it's like an hour and a
you
so they got good coffee they got good
they got good pizza and in the East vage
get you get right here mud if it's still
there mud oh it's probably not there
anymore uh I mean what the [__] do you
know I'm anist you know stop flexing
because I don't even notice what I'm
doing okay see you um was there was one
more thing oh yeah uh she wants us to
make fun of people from England we
already did it oh yeah okay yeah all
right second actually we did that before
she even called second Lucy from
Manchester yeah yeah yeah I wonder if
how people from Manchester feel about
Oasis well I think they love Oasis they
got it right yeah yeah yeah [__] yeah
anyone named Lucy from Manchester loves
Oasis so from Manchester and I have
something in common Lucy is a an English
name I mean dude yeah I had no idea
about that well it's not specifically
only I know that but it's it's uh a
plenty there Lucy is a common name in
England and I'm guessing Manchester
especially because it's like Nigel no
Nigel's more old school okay Lucy's more
people alive now okay in England Nigel
I'm sure there's still a lot of nigels
yeah yeah yeah yeah but it's old school
I get it yeah it's like um Harry or
Henry or what no it's not it's like
London head London head is a very very
common name hello mate my name is London
head what you want to do play [__]
Cricket or whatever
ah [__] what Castle do you live in I
live in one wow oh for [__] sake why
go go are you why are you saying London
like England is London well because it's
just a place in London it's funnier than
place in England London is a place in
England I know oh okay I thought you
were actually getting that backwards
getting what backwards that you thought
I thought England was in London yeah why
did you think that because you keep
calling it London like it's the that's
the name of the
country it's funnier that way oh okay
I'm London my name is London head where
we live in England hello are you talking
about dude if you do something crazy
it's mental yeah men yeah that's good um
anyway I've got fre sisters named
Lucy what is that my mom was
M we live in England anyway mental mate
um so yeah okay cool all right well cool
congrats Lucy on what being from
Manchester all right next one [__] oh
[__] so he won't bite himself Chris I
just flew to Ottawa to see your show
unreal got to meet you and whatnot Co I
mean totally blind just completely blind
before I got to your show Chris I met my
biological sister for the first time I
found out about her when I was 18 she
found out about me when she was and you
know she found out a bit she found out
about but after doing that a lot of
people said to me don't you want to meet
your biological mom she also lives in
Ontario this gu the real life Terminator
and I'm torn uh I feel a little selfish
by not beating her uhhuh but I don't
know how I feel about it I was really
adamant about beating just cut cut his
that off wasn't having okay um the deal
is with stuff like that I have no
experience with I mean just just start
losing your [__] mind just all right
you don't feel like you have to do
anything if you don't want to meet
someone who is your biological family
member just simply do not don't get
caught up in like the but but I should
because people like think it's better
like dude no no no no no no you wanted
to meet your sister you did meet your
sister that's good if ever you do want
to meet your biological mother then do
that but only if you want to do that
there's no right way to do stuff like
that and that kind of is a c out of an
answer but it is the answer do not feel
obligated or that you are forced to do
it or you should or that it's like a
right of passage for people in your sit
that's [__] dude just do what you
want to do that you think will make your
life better I have a good thing to say
great go for it I think you should do it
and why is that because uh you're not
always going to have that chance and
what if you kick yourself after she
passes oh well I I meant do it don't do
it now if you don't want to like I'm not
saying decide now forever more do it
tomorrow but like if you don't feel
comfortable doing that yet then don't do
it again I mean maybe if she's ill and
she's dying that's a totally different
she's probably still young he's he's
young yeah but what is she in her like
50s maybe 60 with that guy as her son
yeah 60 that's still pretty young unless
she had him when she was old you know
but yeah I don't know I don't know if
she if there's a health thing going on
obviously is a different story but you
don't need to do it just because don't
do it also met your sister yeah you feel
pressure don't do it because uh you
think you should do it because you want
to and if you are going to do it because
you feel like you should do it when
you're ready like just be ready for it
and whatever it might be what if you
hate her what if you love her so much
like it's there's so many ifs that or
variables if you don't feel comfortable
doing it don't do it yet don't do it
don't do it but definitely wear those
sunglasses the whole time don't do
it okay okay yeah more next one can we
get one with beautiful
lighting what up Chris and Matt what up
Matt and Chris just want to ask you guys
a quick question today um what do you do
when you find yourself being a
stay-at-home Dad how much is this a guy
a young preacher he looking for a job um
with limited hours available to give to
companies um I haven't really enjoyed
many of the job interviews that I've had
or the options that I have to work with
um and every time that I get into a
part-time job it either doesn't pay or
I'm uninterested within the first couple
weeks of doing the job um my girlfriend
makes good money so we're well taken
care of at home uh but I just want to uh
help them out in any way I can and bring
own the dough to help my family uh and
show my baby girl that uh Daddy's going
out there and working oh that's cool um
appreciate what you guys do uh let me
know what you think um thanks for making
me laugh and chuckle peace out thanks
bro only fan Solo solo only fans you
don't if you don't need to
work only only keep a job that you
like yeah right but I also do understand
he wants to set a good example for his
daughter and also wants to contribute
totally I mean 100% but like if you
don't need to work and it's technically
at the end of the day it's optional make
sure it's a thing you like especially
dude if it's a really low-paying job and
it doesn't matter but a thing you like
you're in a great situation you can do a
job that pays like [__] but that is cool
there are a lot of jobs like that that
the reason they pay so low is because
they're good like easy either easy or
fun or whatever like people take that
into account and pay [__] for it uh so
if pay really doesn't matter
then just get a job that is like
enjoyable for you because you can get
any job because the job doesn't matter
because you don't need the money this is
a good good situation for you do
something easy like stand up yeah do
something easy like and that nobody else
does like be an astronaut or something
there's so few people that are
astronauts just get in there are there
actually few people who are astronauts
yeah because it's so hard to do oh mean
you know it's just weird to do that joke
because I I would have thought you would
have done it hard to do and
also everyone does it like we need more
[__] podcast hosts oh that's not that
hard though very easy yeah pretty easy
uh yeah
um yeah I I I you know what are your
passions lead with that lead with that
and not the money thing cuz you don't
have to that's good you're in a good
position so what you like to do what do
you want to do honestly what do you like
to do for real like you know say you
love to play basketball you're not going
to be in the NBA but maybe you could do
something with that yeah you could teach
Camp yep you know what I'm saying yep
Camp instructor exactly lead with the
[__] you really love if you love eating
what what what what you work at a what a
restaurant you Chef I don't know but
like don't do anything but think about
the things you like and work uh all out
from there I mean you basically have the
everyone's dream scenario is that a they
don't have to work and so because of the
financial situation so like but you want
to work cuz you want to set a good
example which is great that's very cool
but like don't just get any rank R ass
job cuz like you said you're just going
to want to quit because that's like what
he said he's quit a couple jobs that he
started right yeah so stop taking jobs
that you don't think are going to be
[__] fun man I wonder if he's
depressed you know he doesn't seem
depressed at all he doesn't seem
depressed no but that's what depressed
people do yeah well well anyway all
right I'm going to be in Pittsburgh I'm
going to be in Cleveland here I come
Detroit here I come Long Beach
California here I come Chris leah.com
I'll be in Baltimore I'll be in oh [__]
I'll be in go I'll be in Virginia
irginia I'll be there I'll be in
Baltimore I'll be in Richmond I'll be in
uh Trenton New Jersey Philadelphia yada
yada reading all all pleas to come but
uh if you have a question click the link
that uh thing below and
patreon.com Lifeline luxury a new
episode of Lifeline luxury is out today
so go get that right now and go get that
and all of the months worth of episodes
that we have there already
um yeah you want a one-on-one with me
you want it come and get it mat you're
going to get it monoo huh you want it
mata.com it's
aggressive the merch is at Lifeline
merch.com get it or you you do not like
our family and beyond that you wish
death upon us yes so there you go and
like And subscribe and leave a comment
thanks a lot
guys
hello
hello hello